Matthew you're filming wasteland not too
far from your hometown weren't you what
was it like filming up in Leeds it was
cool I mean ever since I was five years
old I've worked all over the country
filming in different places but but
never never in my own tiny wooden job
after Carol Potter called the syndicate
I was the first time I worked in Leeds
then all of us all of a sudden mated to
like London buses to come Lawrence and
I'm working late and and the only one
with the natural legs accent i felt
quite a responsibility with the other
lads I mean I remember Luke Luke
straightaway said to me goes you know at
any point if you see something that you
feel it's not right just just tell me
and yeah we were really keen on that and
and I'm Brad he won everyone and Luke
round Mouse for a game of poker one
night with my mates and Jarrod came and
watched the rugby at the pub with us all
and she's really trying to get that
camaraderie and i felt quite a
responsibility that that i had to you
know find the nice pub for it to go on
happening and i love that i love showing
people around my arm say so i was a real
privilege for me Luke did you real I'm
faster stability so well done on that
one yeah I try my best you know I I love
it so much I love being on me I'm in
London at the MINIX I'm doing a show in
the West End but already I can't wait to
get back home and see all my mates and
that so it was quite nice to be able to
wake up in my own bed and go to work for
a change and tell me about the courses
you say they have to do the Leeds accent
don't they how were they didn't have any
tips for them not at all though oh
really really good I mean Jared's from
from Manchester so he's not far Farley
touched anyone who's as Welsh as they
come managed to do a crack in Leeds
accent very impressed and yeah and Luca
Luca exactly the same so it was sort of
like I said earlier like they were keen
that if they ever thought there was an
issue just a jump in but I really had to
do it to be honest with you they all
work you know so meticulous in their
research that it was never really became
an issue and of course one of the
biggest characters you've had one that
you're so well known for is Neville
Longbottom isn't even the Harry Potter
series how would you compare for people
who know that your character in
wastelands well quite different
you know Dodds Dodds very streetwise
he's rough-and-ready it's just a
working-class lad labourer who lives on
the on a council estate you know in in
south-southeast leads and yeah I mean
he's he's not shy of he's not that he's
not the sharpest knife in the drawer you
know he's not you know a bit like
Neville but he's not shy when it comes
to compensation you know he thinks
someone's someone's condom or some
Finney's it'll go and throw his weight
around so yeah quite quite quite a
different style of different
confrontation approach to Neville
definitely really worried what I'd away
from it from it and how do you feel
about moving on to different things than
Harry Potter do you feel that you find
the lady Neville to rest as it were I
don't know I mean I'm very fortunate
with the character that I got to play
for so long I get I get I now have the
privilege of you know to see be seen for
things and get scripts that I never
would have got otherwise but at the same
time yeah let me know it's a conscious
thing that I have to try and my best to
play different roles but every role that
I feel like I've done since finishing
Potter has been has been so different
from Neville the hopefully it's not an
issue anymore we'll see I mean at the
minute I'm paying quite a lot of thick
northerners thoughtful we can play an
intelligent Navon or at some point an
LLC coming up next for you well I'm in
the West End until the end of the year
December 15th so that's pretty much
taken up all the concentration but maybe
maybe in the new year when we want
something else
what are you enjoying about trading the
boards as opposed to being on the big
screen I really I love it I mean I'm
really fortunate we got a really great
player to work with and it gets very
similar in terms of this film that the
lads that were with in the company are
absolutely wicked and it's very it's
very similar in terms of it's all about
that banter and that the camaraderie
between the lads so really enjoying that
at a minute and yeah it's a comedy so
you know making people laugh and I'm
feeling the audience's reaction every
night is something that you never get
with films so it's quite a unique
experience and it's going well so far
you